hello minna-san konnichiwa everybody it
looks like I'm wearing the same outfit
as yesterday which if it's crazy and it
doesn't make any sense we're gonna
finish the game now all right
Mitch Conner is everywhere I'm Mitch
Conner it's great again I am I might be
crazy here but I do think Mitch Conner
represents some form of American
politician nope actually we can just
walk in Mitch Conner
is great again are they still talking
about the gay fish no okay just making
sure they just seem traumatized they've
been there for a week all right all
right all right well it doesn't look bad
everywhere so I think we might be all
right all right all right all right all
right all right oh right oh right oh
right oh right oh right oh right oh
right oh right oh right or now
ten-eighty move your hips No okay cool
all right good talk yeah it's the Trump
supporters everybody people like change
don't they he could do whatever he wants
he's mad look up in the window
it's over we lost but we can't lose face
it Kyle thanks to the new kid Carmen is
mayor and there's no one left to help us
that's almost like we're like except
that's Morgan Freeman new kid there's
been some kind of time shift anomaly
Omega I only assume it came from your
ass come to the taco shop we can fix
this I'm Morgan Freeman you're far too
seemed to have blasted a ripple in
space-time continuum that's right my
name is Morgan Freeman here's a picture
of Hanabi Walt's very nice kanabi which
of course means fireworks so they are
dancing underneath the fireworks cue
Instagram I can't believe we haven't
really like paid attention to this
because it's super fun like there's
pictures of stuff okay some stuff
hashtag freedom pals isn't that cute
it's been immersive in a weird way yeah
just me am I talking to an empty
audience here huh has everyone left you
need you didn't care about the ending
okay let's be really you're not that
pretty
plus you're eight so I shouldn't be
judging you okay great
glad we got that out of the way excuse
me I had a soda for lunch okay now you
know that isn't this great you learn new
things every day or thank God we're here
a singie team titty Morgan Freeman says
he can help us stop Cartman he's already
been elected mayor it's the new kids
fault
he ordered a forward in time new kid
your farts have sped up time we have to
somehow go back but what can about
Mitzvah rito from ever rising to power
would hold such power
this is the seven-layer home Cerrito
Chipotle beefy nacho supreme oh man the
last time someone tried it they farted
so bad it created a wormhole that made
time travel possible now I have to warn
you friend once you eat the seven-layer
quesarito Chipotle beefy nacho supreme
there is no going back it sounds good I
wanna assure you have everything you
need before you eat this do you
understand I understand
a true to yourself
ah look we took a picture with Morgan
Freeman no we should just go I don't
think ready to eat the seven-layer
quesarito Chipotle beefy nacho supreme
yes I'm Morgan Freeman so what what
makes you so farty about burritos I
thought it was the being back in time to
before Mitch Conner was sworn into
office you can do it you just have to
believe in yourself you just have to
believe the classic storytelling
you just have to believe oh excuse me
intentional oh my god it's so awkward
[Music]
earless all right Bruce it's stronger
than any bird over leash it
I forgot about the believing in herself
bet I guess oh no you didn't believe
harder now
well where well I wonder where we went
probably scarcer oh it's Christmas it
wasn't that bad with Mitch Conner that
roller coaster listen it's not that
simple I didn't believe in myself how do
I believe myself when everyone is so
mean to me the fractured but Hall that's
ridicu place on Christmas
oh yeah cuz that because mr. Hankey
comes out on the lawn for its creatures
oh yes yes woodland critters and we're
gonna find out I think so
defeat the woodland critters oh wow oh
they have a lot of help dude
oh no no more dark meat or not what are
we gonna do yes of course
but oh yeah I am a Christian okay let me
just charge these prayers
hashtag thoughts and prayers I'm working
on it thank you very much and aren't you
Jewish shut up I'm trying all right I'm
almost am I'm I just got a praise a
little bit oh there we go
it's Jesus Christ and he's God
all right Santa now are we gonna fight
him as what's happening bet okay
we weren't expected Santa to show up
whatever will we do we're in a bit of a
bind rabid II don't be sad Barry shucks
I can just sacrifice myself no no oh
okay
all right well why not no I think about
it oh he sacrificed himself and now they
all Saturdays with us
excellent okay well let's begin on this
420 baby that's my season oh boy I'm
going to do Shakespeare you know we
don't do a lot of damage do we okay this
might be it
I'm gonna block this attack I hate her
she says that all the time whatever you
just did naked yes of course
all rights going down very slowly it's
time for diabetes baby can only really
do this one they can heal each other
Lucifer loves you she meets yeah alright
alright well at least we have a chance
now before I was like a little worried
what else does Santa have he has he can
create a gingerbread
that looks terrible but okay okay now
let's finish this Jim hey you came track
any very nice okay all right I get it
guys I get it your your rebels I
appreciate it
let's confuse this guy hahaha
and we got it already
hopefully he's confused come on no well
he attacks a friend is well I guess
Chapelle okay man I want a place in Poe
I think they released an app actually
from her phone destroy or something like
that I need to check it out alright I
hopefully that did something Adam hey
yeah that's good
kills two of them okay mam ma looks like
what is he healing
sorry but that ya know it's your turn
this is a junior junior man even do
anything and he's down I always feel bad
for killing the Christmas critters
they're so cute
oh I don't know if you can reach all the
way oh you can awesome I am out of luck
[ __ ] oh look at that that was awesome
we got two attacks with Santa
you're gonna Thank You Shannon
give me that we technically killed your
reindeers oh he was crying one of them
that's okey hey we got a new did we get
another one then or we might I think
we're on this sorry why are we going to
rock pit rock beats paper Mitch win
sides actually not bad not bad
now listen boys and girls this is said
this is etem we need to max out all our
skills okay all right okay all right
okay I think okay I think actually oh
wait what is this we got this one
look at that it's very powerful very
Marie forbidden very nice yes yes oh
okay and then I just said hold on there
now on one second there any outfit that
we haven't cried wait you can find them
in efforts tell you now
Mitch Conner Barlow
here we are at the unplanned Parenthood
right before Christmas portions we need
a doctor to look at our friends [ __ ]
lemme guess has got a big crack down the
middle ha ha the mayor has to be stopped
we know how to do it the mayor that
scumbag made that town that [ __ ] always
today we can put a stop to it please
just look at our friends just look at it
oh here it is I'm glad there's the title
actually made sense
ah the sphincter trying to take us back
are you ready for this you can do it you
hit
well it didn't work the first time so I
don't know why so mysterious candy by
the way I'm a I'm an idiot I'm
mentioning in a previous episode and
everyone freaked out just thought I'd
mentioned that now that there's a little
bit of loading time and we don't really
have anything to discuss there's just a
black screen really okay please be over
thank you
Oh what we're back here this is our
first fart when we were we should be
happy that he's made friends in this
town so quickly we came here to hide
more friends just means more trouble
you're being paranoid you need to lay
off that stuff it's changing you thing
that helps me relax from your stupid it
did seem like we weren't really finish
we were doing stop Mitch Conner catch up
to yourself
excuse me they it appears here in
northern timeline cozy own does not yet
support
[Music]
[Applause]
we're not playing superheroes dumbass
come on you kid oh yeah because we were
the king yes yes of course
genius plot land this isn't a dragon hey
Frank [ __ ] you dude I'm great
we don't have time for this stand aside
we have to get to carbon well you'll
just have to get back on and our kick
are we finding our past self good good
good good good well we should be a lot
stronger oh nevermind this is why we
didn't let girls play in the first place
what in the world what does it do
I did nothing oh I'm gonna relay yeah no
I'm gonna beat the crap out of myself
never thought I'd say that right here we
are fairly strong yeah
big strongest warrior can handle these
weirdos well I mean okay special
objective defeat warrior Clyde what oh
he's good
why did the king stop okay Dan that's a
lie go need this computer snap oh he's
confused and he kills his teammate
that's awesome it's nice and it's down
that was easy very easy compared to
everything else we've done alright
figured every more we got to find all
bündchen no chit sir no that's awesome
defeat thief Craig but he knows jujitsu
what if we possibly gonna did all right
now you know what I will which one is
the real well
[Music]
well not that one
that's our but that was your buttonhole
nice that was smooth as butter in your
butt more okay I guess we're going
through all of them there's like the
last big fight or some shoes Rahr Rahr
every 100 and so actually it is kind of
like is it punishes a Jewish joke I
don't know exactly how it works
damn that sucks I wish I could rewind
that now use the gun I get it
and then a punch was that okay and he's
gone I guess we have one more aha jeez
what no no no no no hopefully they don't
have full help at least because they
look damaged right I mean look at them
they have full health okay great okay
great that's what I that's what I wanted
that's this is just what I want
this is great I used the meteors again
which I can't block that's great
they'd charge a lot of our old though
and was a pirate hamster or guinea pig
microaggression he called me a fat ass I
forgot about the microaggressions this
is the best
[Applause]
I sort of went all in on just the king
this time and he's dead but I actually
think we have to kill everyone so that
was kind of pointless oh you worked okay
great good good that that elven really
looks like something else okay let's get
real here okay cool I'm glad that
stright worked it was a bit riskier yes
yeah but we know how to kill him yes I
was just traveling back in time to find
you a cat's missing there's a big reward
wait why you guys already playing
superhero we know what you're up but
you're with the freedom house
we're all freedom pals we're from the
future you fat turd no I'm from the
future I was just coming back to stick a
tooth times to get you guys we aren't
playing anymore
we know everything like are they
connected in her left hand my left hand
but when I was your [ __ ] left hand
[Music]
hello freedom pass time travel ain't it
a [ __ ] Connor what the hell are you
doing here I had a plan to use the new
kid as means to get what I always wanted
but it looks like some do-gooders
traveled back in time to stop me
Cartman I swear to god it was it he
Jennifer Lopez because I still know
something you out don't what's that how
to make someone fart super bad by
hitting them in the solar plexus what
could possibly happen next well the game
is black so I don't know maybe Morgan
Freeman welcome and savers Oh No
okay here we are Connor we're in the
time that a superhero was born recognize
this place new kid yeah oh why have you
brought us here don't you see this is
the night new kid fateful night your dad
[ __ ] your mom
you walked to the mirror don't do this
to him but don't you see King this is
what he wanted out alone to fix it oh
you heard your mother calling for help
so you left your room don't you kid you
can't change the past of course you can
go look huh
where oh sorry
okay don't you see new kid I've given
you an opportunity which will you do new
kid fight the bad guys again fight your
younger self so that you never have to
witness what's behind your parents door
bad guys we're just followers right
you're the little kid with like a
zillion followers right we just thought
well we thought that if you could add us
and maybe know maybe we could have
friends because we don't really have any
followers
oh please add us of course
let's do oh boy selfie anything our
moment moment is finally here
Wow yes of course it's happening that's
happening let's do it
smiley face oh wow James Paris we did
everyone have a 3a in France or now
that's incredible see we did it we did
it everyone don't go through that door
yeah no no no no no go back to bed honey
oh yeah our parents hate each other okay
you did it
you stopped your dad you saved your mom
new hit that's right and now there's
nobody left to stop me I'm off to
another 10200 know who the hell are you
I'm the king
this is your kid from the future our
child from the future
oh god I know something like this would
happen our child knows we've been lying
and wants some answers you're right
kiddo we've been dishonest but only
because we wanted to protect you the
truth is your mom and I have certain
abilities powers that normal humans
don't have I discovered mine when I was
younger
one day I created a facebook profile and
within a few hours I had over three
million followers
my powers are similar except they only
seem to work on Instagram I got four
million followers as soon as I
posted my first picture of course powers
like that don't go unnoticed for long
shortly after that your mother and I
were kidnapped by the government where
they had scientists spending months
doing experiments on us try to figure
out how we were able to gain so many
followers so fast that's what your dad
and I met and fell in love huh Perrin
inside a cold damp government lab yes by
day they ran experiments and by night we
made sweet love oh no my powers combined
with your mother's you received over 10
million followers the minute you were
born and by the time they cut the
umbilical cord
you were already more powerful than all
the Cardassians combined that's why we
had to escape because we knew the
government would use you to do horrible
things and we've been on the run ever
since moving from city to city always
trying to stay one step ahead but
everywhere we go you just can't seem to
stop gaining followers that was about
sometimes they even break into our house
and use our toilet just to be close to
you that's why we've been putting
special medicine in your dinner sweetie
to try to curb your powers but it didn't
work the side effects of the medicine
just gave you really powerful and really
smelly it all makes sense doesn't it re
kiddo oh my god I feel so relieved to
have finally told the truth me too honey
I you know I don't think I need to drink
any more I said I don't need to run from
my problems with pop brownies oh honey I
feel like your future is going to be
totally different now I believe in us
yeah God but what about you sweetie
now that you know the truth do do you
think you can believe in yourself too
leap through time really that's what
we're getting okay now not like this oh
sorry
it's bit anti-climatic when you do Lily
just like you move anything and it just
stops it's gonna really charge it at an
energy press X to believe in yourself
press F we're suppress areas the Ephesus
[Music]
I can downtown South Park but where is
everybody
more importantly what period of time
have we landed we got a step but why
don't we just cut off your hand or
something
stop Mitch Connors inauguration yeah
can't let that happen are we gonna be
like those salty Trump supporters I mean
you're not going anywhere
you are Mitch Conner admit it Carmen no
I'm not how admit it
no ciao I have no control over Mitch
Conner you are Mitch Conner
you've always been Mitch Conner and you
better stop right [ __ ] now then how
do you explain this I'm not doing it
dude [ __ ] you what's the matter cane
shoes on the other hand how [ __ ]
knock it off why are you pissed at him
because he's [ __ ] making it up that's
why I'm not making it up dude that's
your [ __ ] hand as hosts not [ __ ]
charlie me how does he trailing you kid
he's trying to teach me a lesson about
being deceitful
wait so you admit you were making it up
before see this is a troll to get me to
admit I was rolling you guys this is
just when I run it all the [ __ ] friends
at each other's throats
dude come on are you doing that yeah
which means maybe Cartman was just doing
it before well will you admit it Cartman
you see
proves it see what he's doing right I
have no [ __ ] idea
oh how one little issue of mistrust can
rip a team apart
well Freedom Pass who do you attack me
or the king why in the world
I'm not doing it [ __ ] mr. Maddock
kun you're not happy to see me
[ __ ] you cap this is sad it's pretty
confusing at this point I don't any
damage I take goes to the king I can't
do it well I got rules too buddy they're
gonna be me or the Keene
I don't
oh no no no no [ __ ] deflects okay so
anything damaged I do hits kyun anyway
it's how about you Freedom House which
one of us is the real villain in feed
your up who you're gonna fight freedom
now I'm really open to hitting either of
you uh-huh same I can't attack
I have a really good feeling about this
gasps we have to finish Khan egg kun and
then we can finish Kyle I think oh my
god no
[Music]
doesn't heal what what
my brain my brain everybody classic
Michigan I don't know I really don't
know I feel like if Kyle wasn't trolling
he would have just stopped us by now
okay same switch this is oh my god what
is going on
I kind of agree ha ha ha at the same
time
yes help us what wait wait wait wait
wait
dr. Timothy calls no cheating go okay
nice look at that oh oh oh Connors it is
same haha thank [ __ ] god oh my god
[Music]
tell these guys you were just [ __ ]
with me they're gonna just keep beating
the [ __ ] out of both of us yeah dude
Kyle if you're just [ __ ] with us we
have to know you're just making things
more confusing if I was just [ __ ]
with you then so is he right oh I see
I'll admit I was just [ __ ] with you
guys but only if Kyle admits you at
first I'm not seeing anything until he
does you admit it first all right fine
we'll both admitted at the same time all
right
Bogg three we're both saying I was just
[ __ ] with you
I was surprised for too long our town
has been led by a dumbass [ __ ] mayor
who never did anything to stop crime and
now Mitch Carter's gonna talking just
make me mayor already
it's Mitch corner
we made it to begin the inauguration mr.
Connor would you raise your right hand
please
yeah I do solemnly swear
a do solemnly swear
what's going on here just finish the
ceremony everyone listen this is all
just a plan to get more crime in our
town so that the [ __ ] and friends
franchise would be bigger than the
freedom pal franchise of course ma'am
except Sharon has been put into your
drugs and alcohol to raise crime in the
city so that the [ __ ] would have more
crime to fight everything was thought up
by then [ __ ] Mitch Conner rads a fat
raccoon no don't you get it he did it
all go ahead and you kid
show them the selfie you tuck show them
this sip which was that that was that
let me just show it to me and I'll put
it on Connors Instagram for everyone to
see it's uploaded there we go
I'm glad the Coons two gram actually had
some sort of purpose you mean he was
putting poison in our wine and cocaine
yeah I'll tell you that because the new
kid isn't the only person who had a
parent get [ __ ] my dad got [ __ ] when
I was nine years old only two people on
this stage know how that feels
not already Shh I want to hear this my
father will be avenged even if it means
everyone else has to die Mitch Mitch
it's over ha ha ha ha ha I've been here
it's not your fault Mitch what are you
talking about it was me Mitch I'm the
one who [ __ ] your day I didn't I
wanted a future for you how these years
hunting for the person that [ __ ] my
dad and it was my own mother
Mitch try and stay calm [ __ ] you you may
be really cute but even you can't fix
this did he look at you ma'am did he
look you in the eye when he snuck up and
[ __ ] him please tell me you're not
buying into this I didn't kill you for
what you did
well that guy isn't gonna be mayor come
on everybody let's go yes oh that was it
right sister
[Music]
oh my god what an ending but I got
damnit knee
oh my god so
[Music]
I love the whole Mitch counter thing
it's so dumb okay like I would old tied
it together you know that Kunta Graham
the time travel Connor and the backstory
that was brilliant man it's funny how
you know such a complex thing like time
travel is done it's usually done so
poorly in movies but they you know
something like South Park that's so
silly and they really nailed it I was so
good yeah I know they aint got me man
I will say like some parts I find the
game to be a bit oh okay I'll give my
final thoughts after this playing with
your friends honey this is a great town
isn't it I love it here
I'm so glad that all those years ago we
came clean about our child's past I feel
like all those years among like our
lives are different now somehow I love
you and I love you they're not gonna
have sex are they in fact kiddo would
you excuse us for a moment
Oh mommy and daddy have a little
business to take care of upstairs oh you
know my god don't walk in there little
kid oh don't do it no did you really
think you could stop bad things from
happening now
it was underneath the glass catches up
with you he's driving there's only one
truth of Miss Maggie no matter how hard
you try to change the past
you've got a house
[Laughter]
okay so that's the official okay so I
don't know I think the first game was so
good that my expectations for this was
you know way higher obviously and I
think since it was delayed so much a lot
of the anticipation for it to come out
really brewed up a lot and I think that
even made it even worse almost so my
expectation was so high when I played it
and it has a lot of issues the game is
really glitchy I mean I had to restart
the game a couple of times which is more
than most games these days at least I
mean I understand some glitches but you
know there was lip-syncing issues all
the time
loading screens was just atrocious man I
know that's a console thing I would but
I hear that's a big glitch here on the
PC so it's just a shame it just kind of
sours your experience a little bit I
found that it was maybe because I didn't
do enough sidequest
maybe but a lot of the times I just felt
like it's a lot of walking from here to
there all the buddy system I found to be
kind of annoying it just felt like
alright I get it but that obviously the
times were it shined it really did and
it was so funny and everything that you
love about South Park really came
through and it made it worth it it made
it like a really really good game like
that ending got me so good I was
hilarious still I've been just thinking
about it but I mean it we made up right
I was saying I really really enjoyed it
regardless and I can't wait and I really
hope they'll make another game because
they really I think they still really
did a great job and I hope they will
find maybe the issues with this game and
improve upon because they can definitely
be adjusted other than that thank you
guys so much for watching this let's
play our playthrough walkthrough
alright now but with me it's a lot of
fun I really really really enjoyed it
it's been a long time since we had a
long play through every single day it
was a lot of extra especially since I
don't have internet I keep having to
like well it doesn't matter but it was
them it was nice
it brought me back to like and all the
time of the channel and I hope in maybe
not too far in the future we'll do
another one because it's a lot of games
coming out now for Christmas as well so
we'll see you know we'll see but it
really means a lot that you guys stuck
through this with me and I hope you
enjoyed yourself as well and I will if
anything I'll see you back with the
daily videos and in the next let's play
thank you guys
and quite fan